welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the flash movie was one of the
most important reveals at dc fandom
weekend despite not having a trailer
like the batman or the steiner cut or
the suicide squad did
what this movie did reveal from its
early panel and what we learned about
the flash and later panels just
confirmed that we might see
the actual biggest superhero crossover
of all time a flashpoint paradox that
resolves
every loose plot thread from nearly
every dc movie we've ever seen
ties them up together in a bow that
hopefully isn't very shoelaces tied
together because that could totally
screw the multiverse
there is actually so much to unpack
about this movie so i'm gonna break down
everything we know about it and how it
could be the most pivotal event in dc
cinema going forward spoiler warning
against any of my predictions end up
being right
you didn't want to know okay the dc
fandom panel revealed concept art
showing flash's new suit
a more form-fitting organic runner suit
truer i would say to the spirit of the
character
with wings on a helmet and tron style
glowing lines emitting from the chest
sigil
the art shows them fighting alongside
batman and not just any batman that
yellow oval sigil is
keaton batman earlier this summer we
learned that michael keaton was
reprising his role as bruce wayne in
this film but instead of the older
mentor figure we were led to believe
he looks here to be suited up and ready
to beat down anyone
within the borders of his peripheral
vision we also learned that ben
affleck is gonna be returning as batman
in this film hell yeah
and it was confirmed that barry allen
was intentionally never called the flash
in the dc eu
that was a name he picked up from his
crossover earlier this year with the cw
version of the flash on the crisis on
infinite earth's event i like your
outfit
it seems sick and comfy yours is pretty
cool seems safe
and breathable so what does all this
info mean for the flash movie coming in
2022 well directed by it director
andy musquieri and written by christina
hodson the film has been confirmed to
adapt the flashpoint event in the comics
and feature barry allen using his cosmic
treadmill to run
so fast that he can travel precisely to
moments in the future and in the past
which he uses to try to prevent the
death of his mother nora but in these
attempts he splits reality into
alternate timelines and spends a lot of
time in a flashpoint universe
a darkest timeline where batman is the
murderous and cold-hearted thomas wayne
bruce's father and really like
everything's wrong
aquaman's atlantean sunk most of europe
wonder woman's amazonians have taken
over the uk
everyone's fighting but it's an awesome
timeline medlin storyline
and this 2011 crossover event was so
important to dc comics
because it ended with flash condensing
every alternate dc reality into one
universe that was called going forward
the new 52
and based on the way the panel described
the film adaptation
dc cinematic appears to be using this
flash film to do something
similar with the various incarnations of
batman movies superman movies and more
now zack snyder already laid the
groundwork for this in batman v superman
and appears to be revisiting it for his
upcoming director's cut of justice
league after that
nightmare scene in batman v superman the
flash visited bruce from the future
asking if he was too soon and telling
bruce that he was right about superman
and that lois is the key
on social media snyder confirmed his
intention to reveal that barry had been
using the cosmic treadmill
once set up in the batcave beneath wayne
manor to run back in time to bruce to
warn him about the future to tell him to
save lois to prevent superman from going
injustice evil
but that barry went back too far and in
that snyder cut panel snyder confirmed
that he intends to pick back
up with his time travel supply you're
gonna see something with flash in this
film
i don't think that you've ever seen
before something that has to do with his
abilities
because you know he's a quantum
character he does he he
interacts with time and space so you
might see him do something that is
timely i pointed out in my breakdown of
the snyder cut trailer how a brief shot
shows barry
in a kind of wind tunnel reaching
forward toward the light in a similar
pose
as the one through that time portal to
bruce and batman v superman now if you
remember barry's subplot arc in justice
league was to try to prove the innocence
of his father henry who was framed for
the murder of barry's mother nora
and by the end of that movie he got a
job in a crime lab wouldn't surprise me
if snyder keeps this scene
in his recut because of the new footage
snyder deliberately inserted a portrait
of thomas wayne jeffrey d morgan
in the ruins of wayne manor in that
future sequence and i think
all of these clues when tied together
tells us a whole bunch
about this flashpoint film but before we
continue thank you to
magic spoon for sponsoring this episode
like i get it i'm a grown man talking
about children's comic book characters
it's kind of like i'm back waking up
early saturday mornings to watch batman
the animated series with a bowl of
super super sugary cereal but now i
gotta do it and you know take notes for
new rock stars research and you know i
can't really include the same sugary
cereal anymore because i'm
an adult and i have to sometimes think
about my health but now thanks with
magic spoon cereal i can get back to
eating cereal and not feel bad about it
magic spoon has no sugar
11 grams of protein and is only 110
calories
it's also keto friendly gluten-free
grain-free soy-free low-carb and
gm ovary it comes in four flavors cocoa
fruity frosted and blueberry you can try
all four in a variety pack all the
flavors are great but i'm really
enjoying this fruity one it's like a
certain other fruity
loopy cereal but um honestly i like it a
lot better
and it's great knowing that it's
actually good for me i kind of do like
it and it's for grown ups and look they
still give you a word search because um
there's no age limit there just click
the link below to grab a variety pack
and try it today
and be sure to use the promo code new
rockstars at checkout to get free
shipping just go to magicspoon.com new
rockstars
and magic spoon is so competent in their
product it is backed with a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason
they will refund your money no questions
asked click the link below and use the
code new rockstars for free shipping or
go to magicspoon.com
new rockstars okay so from what we can
tell from zack snyder's justice league
won't necessarily
end with the happy ending that
theatrical cut did snyder's trailer
showed the post-apocalyptic future in
which darkseid has ravaged the planet
but he recolored it from the tan filter
he used when it was suggested to be a
dream in bvs
this plus the thomas wayne portrait plus
the aquaman trident and the diana shield
all added to the ruins of wayne manor
that overlooks this riverbed a manner
that was previously abandoned but
restored into the hall of justice after
the events of justice league
all suggest that this is a real future
that awaits the justice league
despite their victory over steppenwolf
nevertheless brought upon by darkseid
and a future that flash will go back in
time to try to prevent and yes i really
think we're gonna get more of this in
the snyder cut because i think a big
reason why the studio funded zack snyder
with 30 million dollars to restore
his snyder cut wasn't just to shut up
fans it wasn't just to secure a ton of
hbo max subscriptions but really kill a
third bird with that stone
just skipping across ducks in a lake to
really use this snyder cut to set up
their big
flashpoint crossover film to close this
dceu chapter in a way that fans find
satisfying
and like the new 52 relaunch in the
comics gets us all to
look forward to a reset future reports
are suggesting snyder's justice league
miniseries could drop
september 2021 which would be pretty
perfect timing because think about it
four weeks leading up to the matt reeves
robert pattinson batman movie dropping
october 2021 four episodes of the
justice league on hbo max
that end with explaining how all these
different batman movies are connected
i think that snyder cut will reveal
barry's discovery of his ability to
travel through time and change things in
different timelines
from his perspective it's a natural gust
of wind a constant of the universe that
he can stumble into but not one that he
himself is god over and like a wind
tunnel he must
forcefully push himself against it in
order to navigate and move along it we
might see a similar visual language used
in the flash
film but in order to move through this
force with minimal resistance he's gonna
need a sleeker suit
which would be inspired by his crossover
with the flash in the cw event he
borrows that suit design and then sets
off back in time to fix the timeline and
in doing so as in the flashpoint comics
barry's gonna splinter reality into
alternate timelines
each with its own incarnation of batman
and other dc characters
ones that we've seen before this is how
we're going to get keaton batman
and rumor has it danny devito penguin in
the same movie as
ben affleck batman but it's also how he
could get jeffrey dean morgan to show up
as thomas wayne batman if they decide to
visit that darkest timeline for the
flashpoint comics i mean think about it
a [ __ ] ton of stuff could get crossed
over
at least according to the screenwriter
in the panel batman lost his parents
[Music]
superman lost his planet
harley quinn lost her egg sandwich
but barry because he's got this ability
to go back and manipulate time
he's the only one who can actually go
and change his own personal story
interesting that hudson brought up
harley quinn's breakfast sandu
because if you look at that extreme
close-up of the flash script page that
they showed
there is some scene in this movie in
which the real barry allen
gets a breakfast sandwich we could be
looking at a crossover in which he saves
harley quinn's sandwich from birds of
prey
and in the panel when they talked about
the dc multiverse of titles that the
flash could theoretically cross over
into
pat montage showed man of steel the 2016
suicide squad
the 2019 joaquin phoenix joker the
christopher reeves superman wonder woman
84
and linda carter wonder woman batman v
superman 89 batman
kilmer batman clooney batman lego batman
hbo's watchmen shazam
the cw batman returns and [ __ ]
constantine now you could argue that
these were just like hypothetical
crossovers a reminder of everything that
dc has done in the warner brothers
movies but no no this panel included a
whole
separate section in which the cast and
crew speculated their more silly what-if
crossover
ideas which i believe makes that
previous list something they're
considering more closely especially if
keaton and devito are definitely
crossing over what's to stop keanu
nothing can stop kion i'm taken on back
i think the ultimate goal of this flash
film will be to redefine the
forward-looking dcu titles like the
batman
or joker as futures disconnected from
the past
but to close the book on each past dc
elseworld so that they don't feel like
forgotten mistakes and the most
important of those would be
zack snyder's dceu the fact that ben
affleck is confirmed as a batman for
this movie
and that jeffrey d morgan is at least
speculated to be in it to me is a very
good sign that we could be getting one
of my favorite moments from the
flashpoint
story in which barry allen passes a
letter written by thomas wayne
to his son it'll break our hearts and
give bruce some long-needed closure and
more importantly give ben affleck the
epilogue his underappreciated take on
batman deserves look there's a lot more
to talk about what we learned at dc's
fandom so be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you get all
the latest updates as we get to them
you should also join our official
discord server where we go even deeper
into these nerdy conversations
and gives you an inside scoop on our
thought process how we find all this
stuff
you can access it of becoming a patron
of new rockstars at any tier even one
dollar a month just go to
patreon.comrockstars
you can follow me on instagram ea boss
follow new rockstars thanks for watching
[Music]
you